hey 42 here even the most rugged and
hardiest of men cries sometimes there's
no escaping the tear in fact study
suggests that you probably cry a lot
more than you think you do during a
study by the German society of
ophthalmology they found that women cry
on average between thirty to sixty four
times per year whereas men cry between
six and seventeen times per year women
are actually biologically hardwired to
be more susceptible to crying women have
60% more prolactin in their bodies than
men prolactin is a reproductive hormone
which is also found in tears and is
partially responsible for women being
more prone to tearing up on the other
hand testosterone a hormone which is
more abundant in males inhibits crying
however this difference in the frequency
of Tears shared between genders doesn't
come into effect until the age of 13
before they are 13 both girls and boys
cry the same amount men and women don't
just differ in how frequently they cry
they also cry for different durations
studies show that men tend to cry for
between two to four minutes whereas
women cry for an average of 6 minutes
maybe this is why in almost every
culture on earth it is more socially
acceptable for women to cry than men
certain cultures actually Shawn crying
all together for both genders seeing it
as undignified under infantile despite
the negative connotations they may carry
tears are most certainly a force for
good they can call others to help you
and even heal you from within but why do
humans cry in the first place let's find
out
and they may all look the same on the
surface but there are three different
types of Tears and they're all quite
unique
the first kind of tear is basal tears in
all mammals the cornea of the eye is
continually kept wet by basal tears our
eyes are some of the most vulnerable and
sensitive parts of our outer body so
it's incredibly important that they are
protected at all times the basal tears
ensure our eyes are well protected from
bacteria and irritants basal tears are
made up of three distinct layers the
first layer which sits directly on the
eye surface is the mucous layer this
helps to tear to spread out and coat the
entire eyeball it also keeps the eye
moisturized the next the middle layer is
the aqueous layer consisting mostly of
water it contains vitamins and nutrients
keeping the cornea healthy this layer
also contains salt which acts as an
antibacterial this is why tears taste
salty and the third outermost layer is
the lipid layer this layer made up
entirely of oils acts as a sealant to
stop your tears evaporating and keep
bacteria and over irritant out this
layer also makes your vision sharp the
convex of this oily film which coats
your cornea creates an incredibly smooth
surface this helps to smooth out the
natural bumps and fissures of your
cornea which can cause blurred vision
this is why people get blurry vision
when they have dry eyes the second type
of tear is the reflex tear these are
only released when foreign particles
make contact with the eye which could
irritate or even damage the eye for
example pepper spray tear gas capsicum
and of course onion vapors when these
potentially harmful substances make
contact with the cornea reflex tears are
produced to wash them away and finally
the last kind of tear is what has
perplexed scientists for so long
psychogenic tears when we talk about
someone crying sobbing or weeping we are
usually referring to psychogenic tears
these are tears that are caused by
strong emotions and physical pain it
might be stressors at work or at home a
family member passing away or perhaps a
pet or maybe a painful breakup with a
loved one but psychogenic tears aren't
exclusively caused by negative emotions
we can also turn on the waterworks when
we're overwhelmingly happy or during an
intense bout of laughter that covers all
the different types of tears but all
tears originate from the same place all
human tears are formed in the lacrimal
gland resembling a raspberry it sits
just above your eyeball it may be small
in size but it's easily one of the most
complex systems in the whole human body
tears are formed inside it then the
small bulbs that make up its unique
shape contract to pump the tears
downwards exiting through little tubes
and ending up on your eyeball your
blinking is actually synchronized with
your lacrimal glands when a new tear is
released from the gland whether it be a
basal reflex or psychogenic tear you
automatically and subconsciously blink
this blinking motion spreads the new
tear evenly across the surface of your
eye once a tear has covered your eyeball
it has two possible exit routes the
first is the standard route down the
lacrimal punctum think of this as the
drain on your kitchen sink there are two
lacrimal punctum in each eye they are
located on the inside of your eyelids in
fact if you're so inclined these tiny
little drainage pumps can be seen with
the naked eye if you look really really
closely their sole job is to drain tears
from your cornea once the tear has
served its purpose the tears that make
their way down the lacrimal punctum
are drained down through your nose which
is why your nose get stuffy when you cry
the second possible escape route for it
here is of course down your cheek and
then if you just gone through a breakup
probably straight into a tub of ice
cream so what happens when you fill the
sink up too high and it's at risk of
overflowing
the water goes through the overflow and
that's exactly what happens when you
produce tears faster than your lacrimal
punctum can drain them away when the
lacrimal punctum gets overloaded the
excess tears have nowhere else to go and
so they roll down your cheeks there is a
system in your brain specifically
designed for dealing with emotions it's
called the limbic system when we get
emotional a limbic system is activated
the limbic system is hardwired with our
autonomic nervous system which is the
control center for the function of our
internal organs the autonomic nervous
system is connected to and can control
every major organ in your body and
thereby the limbic system can influence
and use this immense power this is how
emotions can affect us physically but
for instance emotions can cause shaky
and clammy hands and increased heart
rate sweating stomach cramps and of
course
crying but what's the point in tears why
is it that when we get upset the limbic
system in our brain feels it necessary
to alert our autonomic nervous system to
command the lacrimal glands above our
eyes to start rapidly producing these
weird oily salty drops of water well
just like most human functions and
behaviors there's usually a solid
evolutionary reason for having said
function if humans can do something it's
usually because there's a bloody good
reason for it or at least there used to
be in this respect crying is no
different to most of our human abilities
it's believed that crank also has its
roots in evolution for any ability to
have survived a ruthless critic that is
evolution it must in some way be
beneficial to our survival
but what are the survival benefits of
crying well there are actually two major
benefits of turning on the waterworks
which explain why we have the ability to
cry in the first place the first benefit
is that it makes us feel better get this
we don't actually cry because we feel
sad we cry to get over being sad crying
is our body's own morale booster and
healer of mental
wounds 90% of people report feeling
happier and less stressed after crying
when you cry and someone says let it out
they really mean it because when we cry
we are quite literally crying our
stresses away stress causing chemicals
that build up when we're under emotional
tension are physically removed from the
body in our tears when we cry crying
also stimulates the release of
endorphins in the brain endorphins are
the happy hormone they relieve stress
and lift up your mood the second benefit
of crying is communication before humans
developed language some of the only
forms of communication we had were basic
noises such as laughter and sobbing when
our ancient ancestors hurt themselves or
were feeling upset the sight of tears
rolling down their face will have
spurred their cohorts to come to their
rate this exact same behavior can still
be seen in babies today since babies
can't talk they use tears to communicate
when some fingers wrong whether it be
pain hunger or tiredness or perhaps
they're just missing their mommy crying
works so well to attract an office
attention because humans are genetically
programmed to feel sympathy for people
who are in tears
psychologists demonstrated this in a
study where they digitally remove tears
from pictures of people crying and
monitored people's sympathetic response
all the participants judge the people in
the images with tears to be sadder than
in the images without tears studies show
that crying is also good for your health
a good sob lowers your blood pressure
and removes unwanted toxins from your
body there has even been evidence that
crying can help to regulate your immune
system in particular during a study it
was found that people who have recently
had a good cry were less susceptible to
allergic reactions and eczema crying is
one of the most basic yet powerful forms
of communication that we possess it can
heal your mind and your body relieve
stresses and bring people closer
together and there's certainly no shame
in
fine to the view subscribe for more 42
you